la pandémie a bouleversé nos vies et
elle à accentuer certains phénomènes
comme l'engouement pour les pôles
urbaine en plus de données d eux ces
petites boules de plumes sont une source
de divertissement inespéré mais
attention la pio sécurité ni pas à
prendre à la légère
[Musique]
le grand marché de québec fait le
bonheur des passants aujourd'hui
on expose des poules des poules urbaines
de toutes les couleurs c'est au tour de
la ville de québec d'autoriser la garde
de poule c soit en 2021 environ soixante
dix municipalités urbaines et
périurbaines l'ont déjà permis à leurs
citoyens comme saint-hyacinthe montréal
trois rivières drummondville où les vies
les citadins peuvent garder leur poule
derrière la maison ça fait plaisir de
les gâter à chaque jour
pour pascal jobin s'occuper de paul à la
maison apporte des bienfaits
mais pour le med à gérer mon acceptez
donc m'occupe l'estrie je me sens
vraiment bien en leur présence puis les
poules c'est drôle donc il n'y a pas on
peut pas être marabout en présence de
poule mais le pôle urbain vient avec
leur lot de soucis elles peuvent parfois
avoir des ennuis graves de santé j'ai eu
beau lire énormément sur l'épaule
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux lire les
conseils je pensais que j'étais préparé
mais je n'étais pas suffisamment
définitivement puis encore aujourd'hui
je suis un processus d'apprentissage
continu
les vétérinaires n'était ni formés ni
préparés à ces nouvelles demandes des
régions se trouvent même sont si riches
en période de pandémie je crois qu aucun
mais tu es una qui voyait venir
minc ça aurait j'en ai acheté après
avoir le vétérinaire jean françois
lapointe en montérégie a été un des
premiers à se perfectionner dans le
domaine sa pratique dédié à ton plaît
aux bovins laitiers a été bouleversé par
l'arrivée de poules en ville c'est
maintenant 50 pour ça mon travail
presque
le vétérinaire traite principalement de
maladies infectieuses et certaines ne
préoccupe plus que d'autres
définitive masque j'aime le moins sont
la rencontre acquis depuis mycoplasme
par la côte et portera symptomatique
insidieux j'en vois beaucoup des gens
qui malheureusement ont accueilli chez
eux un animal un oiseau de quelqu'un
d'autre puis la maladie ça recommence
[Musique]
mais toutes les poules ne sont pas
malades les éleveurs urbain et
périurbain achètent leur poule de deux
manières
80% des poules proviennent des meuneries
ou quincaillerie le plus gros
fournisseur et le réseau qu à soyaux les
poussins élevés dans des troupeaux
commerciaux ont été vaccinées donc ne
sont pas porteurs de maladies et
l'environnement de biosécurité stricte
et cartes ou si l'enjeu de santé humaine
on a la chance au québec d'avoir dans
les troupeaux commerciaux un programme
de prévention détection où on en a pas
de salmonelle mes voeux pour cent des
poules urbaines proviennent de petits
élevages de type basse cour dont on
ignore le statut sanitaire et le citadin
ne peut pas savoir si ces poules
convoités sont porteuses ou non de la
salmonelle ça demeure un risque pour la
santé publique ça démarre à vis pour le
propriétaire ça demeure un risque pour
les enfants et le consommateur d eux
aux etats unis en 2020 les centers for
disease control rapporte 700 personnes
malades de la salmonelle reliés à des
oiseaux de basse-cour 25 % étaient des
enfants 300 personnes ont été
hospitalisées locale a pas beaucoup de
plumes sur le vent contrairement à la
salmonellose les maladies savières comme
les infections par mycoplasme ou largo
trachéite ne représente pas un danger
pour lui-même
donc fait un apport est intégré bien sûr
oui exact ça fait trois semaines qu'elle
lise et j'ai attendu deux semaines dans
le poulailler c'est paris plage et s'est
désintégré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marcus la brute comme le risque de
propagation et grands avant que nouvel
oiseau intègre le poulailler la
quarantaine devraient est obligatoire le
vétérinaire recommande aussi un
dépistage
j'ai fait un échantillon pour m'assurer
qu'à l'époque bactéries
c'est fini cette poule n'a pas les yeux
qui coulent la tour ou un gros rhume
mais elle pourrait être infecté par un
mikko place car souvent rien n'y paraît
et la contamination se propage
des porteurs asymptomatiques peuvent
être six mois sans symptômes
j'ai vu des corps à cette triste pour
l'autre infection de type lingots
trachéite le vétérinaire y va d'un
traitement préventif
là je vais lui donner le vaccin contre
la rencontre à qui tu te maladie virale
quand même assez sévères puis bon ceci
me toute nouvelle que j'ai pris les
éleveurs sont pas vaccinés les poules
qui proviennent des grandes mairies ont
toutes reçu ce vaccin
jeu ça soit parlante au fait
comme largo trachéite est causée par un
virus de type herpès les poules qui ont
survivent reste porteuse avis
j'ai vu des cas où des gens avaient
recueilli des poules du voisin qui se
développe une affaire où une poule que
j'appelle de sauvetage ou rescue le
puits cette pole est apporté aux
différentes d'une maladie la rencontre à
quitte entre autres qui est dommage à
puis il ya eu 30 % de mortalité dans un
cheptel de quelqu'un qui en avait 100
donc ça c'est assez triste à voir le pc
s'est passé pas vraiment beau à voir le
celi sont très malades
les vétérinaires met en garde les
éleveurs contre l'automédication qui
peut mener à une surmédication la
résistance aux antibiotiques et tous
présents chez les oiseaux de basse-cour
puisqu'on sait puis on le voit lorsqu'on
visite un peu certains réseaux sur
internet c'est que les gens s'échangent
entre eux des produits chaque médicament
selon le dosage selon la durée du
traitement faut respecter un temps de
retrait où il faut jeter les
puissants clairement c'est ça vient pas
avec le médicament si on la jette du
beau-frère sur internet
les poulaillers commerciaux contrôler la
santé de leurs oiseaux et depuis 1997 au
québec aucun cas de salmonelle n'a été
détectée dans les troupeaux commerciaux
c'est plutôt les éclosions dans les
basses cours que la directrice de la
chaire de recherche on sentait avicole
de l'université de montréal cré les
déjections animales
ces deux animaux sauvages qui peuvent
être présenté un potentiel de
contaminants
un animal sauvage autour du poulailler
peut laisser des chalonnais c'est
impressionnant là quand cette semaine
elle qu'on peut retrouver dans les
fientes des rongeurs
une fois la pole infectés la bactérie
est présente dans l'oeuf
si le jaune et consomment en fait ne
fait que consommer puis malcuit et puis
on retrouve la salmonelle dans le jaune
à ce moment là les gens vont développer
diarrhées fièvre des douleurs
abdominales dont la sévérité varier
selon la charge qui vont avoir ingéré
comme les fientes et la litière peuvent
être contaminés le mot d'ordre de la
chercheuse ne jamais laisser les oeufs
sur le comptoir à la température de la
pièce
si à risque qu'une bactérie salmonella
par exemple voient se multiplier se
disait en deux ans 20 minutes imaginez
la charge qui vont se développer à
l'intérieur d'un oeuf vous allez vous
retrouver après plusieurs avec une
population exponentielle de salmonelle
est votre rêve de vie littéralement une
bombe biologique
en 2020 en ontario des cas de salmonelle
en basse cour où été rapporté même à
petite échelle élever des animaux
vieille avec des responsabilités de
prévention et de précaution je crois que
l'important c'est d'éduquer les gens qui
considèrent qu'ils possèdent des pôles
de façon à ce que tout un chacun soit
connaissant des risques sont inhérents à
posséder des poules urbaines on parle de
bien-être animal je pense qu'un peu de
biosécurité
éviterait beaucoup de maladies puis fait
une augmentation du bien-être en général
de ce pôle
somme toute elles vont très bien que son
héroïsme
[Musique]